o sol tímido mais um vídeo e hoje vou
fazer um box do meu primeiro dono que
este aqui o de 7 380 e eu conseguia
fazer um trabalho para uma empresa e
eles deram com forma de pagamento ou
seja este vídeo aqui não é patrocinar o
próprio contar aqui por tirar tudo da
caixa como é óbvio
uma coisa que não gostei muito e que só
tem quatro elas só sei se vocês pegarem
uma tem que comprar elas mas acho que
com quase todos os drones hoje em dia
porque é uma maneira que eles têm para
fazer um dinheiro extra depois vender
droga
aqui está o carregador de bateria que é
só encaixar neste bloco depois da
alimentação do outro lado e isso fica
carregado quando a luz para buscar a
caixa 30 mas este craque que é muito
fácil de usar basta você quer ganhar em
bateria ligá lo depois ligou a câmera do
drone estamos ver logo que está a
acontecer à vossa frente
depois tem a opção de voto e virarem
câmera para cima e para baixo é para
você chegar ontem que vai ligar o
comando depois tem que encaixar na
bateria e por estas partes amarelo e
assim desta forma agora eu não gosto
muito fino tem um botão de ligar e
desligar ou menos eu não encontrei um
pode estar bem escondido aí é muito
difícil vocês tirarem e forem bateria
porque ela conexão fica mesmo da empresa
é por outro lado é festeira bateria
desta forma porque assim eu posso depois
dessas aula em outros projetos no futuro
aqui no canal podem ver diz ajudar
naquela quarta câmara vai pra cima ou
então para baixo e as tenha qualidade
aqui de imagem do ecrã
agora você já está a pensar bem mas não
é sim uma qualidade do outro mundo até
morrer se não também não é sim muito
caro a quem fala então é normal que não
seja tudo brigando aí sim eu pensei vou
testar o nec matando ela mesma província
de khon kaen banho delas e ainda bem que
fiz isso porque eu coloquei ao contrário
os braços do drone tem uma seta
sindicato por aquele lado que as células
vão girar e você tem que colocar lá elas
e gerar para a direção indicada de forma
que quando elas viraram nessa direção
guaruva para vários podem ver
e depois de fazer a alteração o drone já
voava como deve ser
o texto é bastante rápido eu estava com
medo que hoje em dia tem que reclamar
porque faz muito barulho e agora parte
mais divertida aqui atestar o drone e
tivemos muita sorte porque no dia a
seguir a um boxe estava assim muito
bonito mesmo sem nuvens no céu azul e
vamos para são martinho do porto que é
uma paraíba estão perto de onde nós
moramos e também muito feliz que o
miguel tem um tamanho um drone que é
muito melhor que o meu e tem muita
experiência então foi feito porque os do
mep luta logo no início explicou como
funciona as coisas mais ou menos no
início éramos para voar de cima com o
meu droga mas como estava muito vento e
nós nunca estamos de luto
então pensamos até em criar é melhor
irmos lá para baixo de estar num sítio
assim mais masculino ok
aí vocês conseguem ver que as imagens
pra esconder o anel
estou muito feliz e eu tenho muita pena
não mostrar sim e com isso dando aqui
com o meu porque esquecido carregar
bateria da câmera
pensava que a câmara era alimentada com
a energia do drone só que afinal não tem
carregar a bateria no futuro e vou
mostrar a qualidade de imagem desta
câmara e estava muito vento estava muito
coisa estava controlado no caso estranho
estava aprendendo início do mês mais pro
final já conseguiu voar como deve ser
feito e lembra
é porque elas vão fazer mais vídeos do
canal em inglês e aos ataques ainda é
isso que espero que vocês tenham gostado
deste vídeo foi muito divertido e isso
fez bem até a próxima reunião